- [Stray Kids] Step out.
Hello, we are Stray Kids.
(all cheering)
- Gather round, it's your boy Bang Chan.
Woo.
- You're not a boy.
- What?
- Okay, you're adult.
- Seungmin in the studio.
- Oh, Seungmin in the studio.
- Nice.
- Dog person, Hyunjin.
- Oh, dog person. (chuckles)
- Hello, Felix.
- Yeah.
- Hello, I'm I.N.
Hi, I'm Han.
#LovePuppies.
- Hi, I'm Lee Know.
- [Bang Chan] Lee Know.
- Hello, I'm Changbin.
(all cheer)
- Nice.
- And we are going to be
doing an interview with Buzzfeed with...
- [Stray Kids] Puppies!
- Puppies.
- Where's puppies?
- Are you guys ready, puppies?
- Where's my baby?
(all talking over each other)
(Han & Hyunjin babbling)
(all four babbling)
(mellow synth music)
- [Stray Kids] Ohh!
- Oh my God.
My lovely puppies.
(members babbling)
- Hi.
(toy squeaking)
(mellow synth music)
- Domino!
- Domino?
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wow, um...
I think we guys love to
perform "God's Menu."
"God's Menu," "God's Menu," "God's Menu?"
Yes, "God's Menu."
(mellow synth music)
- I can talk with dogs.
- Oh, you can really?
(Hyunjin babbling)
(members laughing)
- It's the language.
(Hyunjin babbling)
Hey, what's your name?
- So I like making my
own computer and, like,
adjusting the pipes and screws.
(toy squeaking)
- They're so cute!
Come here! (laughs)
(mellow synth music)
- He's in a slump right now.
- Play with puppies?
- Play with puppies.
- Play with puppies and members.
Ah, don't fight!
Hang out with friends or watching movies.
- [Hyunjin] Oh yeah.
- Wow, they're really... healthy.
(mellow synth music)
- Stretching!
(all talking over each other)
Cheering up, cheer up?
- Fighting!
- So, like, before we
go on stage, we say, like,
"Ah, let's do well today!
And let's not get hurt
and stay strong," and then
that's how we--
- Let's break our legs!
- Yes, a way of cheering.
- Yes.
(mellow synth music)
- Our STAYs.
- We always never changed.
- Yeah, always have STAY.
- Oh, always STAY.
- Wow, wow.
(mellow synth music)
- "Hellevator."
(all talking over each other)
- When we made "Hellevator" music video!
- It was fun.
- Actually, that was not fun,
but can't forget.
- New experiment.
- Yeah, new experience.
- Yeah, good experience.
That was our first music video.
(mellow synth music)
- Well, my coffee machines
are getting upgraded.
(all cheer)
- This is our personal coffee machine.
- And we're using it all together.
- Besides me.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- The control was so difficult to control,
like, machine's so...
So now, I'm not using it.
(mellow synth music)
- Puppies!
- Yes.
- Yes, like cute guys.
(all talking over each other)
- For loving puppies.
- Life friends!
You guys know life friend?
Korean is called - "insaeng chingu"
and it's really have deep mean.
- They look like Stray Kids.
- [Han] Yeah.
- [Bang Chan] Yeah.
(mellow synth music)
- Drink milk! (laughs)
- Eat more!
And drink milk!
(I.N. laughing)
Please.
What's wrong with you?
Go to JYP and join the audition
when you're 17 years old.
- Yes!
- [Stray Kids] Ohh!
- And you gotta start swimming, okay?
For your shoulder and
your back muscles, okay?
Please.
(mellow synth music)
- Why are piggy banks so wise?
Because they're filled with common cents.
(all laugh)
(Bang Chan babbling)
- [Felix] So funny.
(mellow synth music)
(Han meows)
- Felix.
- Oh, really?
- Why me?
- And small hands.
(toy squeaking)
- Yeah, small hands.
(mellow synth music)
- Monday chest, Tuesday back!
(members laugh)
- Monday is chest.
Tuesday is back.
Wednesday is shoulders.
- [Felix] Shoulders.
- And Thursday is legs.
- I skip leg day.
(mellow synth music)
- Ouch!
- I mean, I really did a
collaboration with Nayeon sunbaenim
and that song is called "No Problem."
Later on in the future, I guess for fun,
I will probably sing sometimes.
So cute, come here!
(mellow synth music)
- Art was my friend, so it feels
like being happy, happy.
- Ah, I see, happy.
Yeah, makes me happy, so...
My favorite art collection...
My flowers with oil.
(Felix laughs)
I love oceans.
- Oh, oceans.
- Yeah, oh my God.
- He can't concentrate,
'cause he's biting the shoe!
(upbeat synth music)
- You guys must watch that K-drama
It's really fun.
And I made a song about that yesterday.
- Yesterday.
- Yeah, and...
I will show you one day.
Thank you.
(mellow synth music)
- [Han] Oh, rapper!
- You have to rap.
- Hey, Seungmin.
- My future plan is to beat
Han and Changbin for rapping.
- [Stray Kids] Ohh!
- I have a big plan,
so please look for it.
(mellow synth music)
- Thousands.
(all talking over each other)
- Stray Kids demos, there's still a lot
that we haven't released.
- Yeah.
- But they're not only just, you know,
Stray Kids team songs.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- There's also, you know,
demos that, you know,
members have made individually,
which haven't been out yet.
You're a machine, aren't you?
Oh my god.
(Chan growling)
(mellow synth music)
- One day, I just want to
travel this whole world.
Maybe with you.
- Really?
- Yeah, shall we?
Sad.
(sad trumpet plays)
- I want to make my own café.
- [Stray Kids] Oh!
(Bang Chan vocalizing)
(dog barks)
- I need to invite you guys too.
Okay?
- It's okay, it's okay.
- I feel like Changbin has his own.
- You wanna make own (speaks
in foreign language).
- (laughs) His own gym!
- I wanna make my gym.
- Yeah, lovely!
- [Stray Kids] Ohh!
- He said, like, he wanna
produce his own song.
- I wouldn't say it's
a goal, but I'd be glad
to get the chance to--
- Woo!
- I'd love to raise my own dog.
- Yeah!
(all talking over each other)
Like you little munchkins!
Come here, come here, come here!
(toy squeaking)
(mellow synth music)
- "Grow Up?"
- [Stray Kids] Ah!
- It does a good job, yeah.
- "Grow Up," yeah, me too.
"Grow Up."
- Agreed.
- The lyrics are so emotional.
(Han makes wailing noises)
- I like the song that Han wrote.
Um, "Slum."
(members talking over each other)
I like "Slum."
(mellow synth music)
(Stray Kids babbling)
(toys squeaking)
- 2:00 AM.
- It can be, like, in the
morning, it can be at night.
It could be on the plane.
- Taking a shower.
- A lot of stuff comes out
when you take a shower.
I think it's because, like,
you're really relaxed,
so maybe that might be why.
(Bang Chan laughs)
- They're so playful.
- Wow.
(mellow synth music)
- Wow, that's a good question!
- Um, maybe.
- Ahh!
- I hope so.
- I mean, we don't have
any plans yet, but...
- [Han] No, not yet.
- That'd be nice, maybe.
We could.
- Yeah.
We can release a "WOW" 2!
- Oh! (claps)
- "WOW" 2!
- Jesus!
- Jesus.
(Felix laughs)
(mellow synth music)
(Bang Chan beatboxing)
- Show me what you got!
- [Felix] It is embarrassing.
(Bang Chan beatboxing)
♪ Today we're at BuzzFeed ♪
♪ Playing with puppies ♪
♪ I'm feeling so lucky ♪
- Hey!
♪ I feel so great, ah ♪
(Stray Kids laughing)
- [Han] Great, yeah!
- Don't make me do this again.
- That was pretty good.
- Look at how red he got, he's so red!
(Stray Kids laughing)
- Next question.
(mellow synth music)
Oh, yes, of course!
- The recent one that we, I
guess, shared by ourselves,
it was the one where we
were so synchronized.
- Oh!
- Where we did the same action
like, yeah, same action.
Yeah, that was crazy.
(toy squeaking)
(Bang Chan babbling)
(mellow synth music)
- Bbama is really big and huge.
- Oh really?
What do you know?
- Kkami don't like other puppies.
- Yeah, same.
Berry thinks that she's a person.
(Hyunjin laughs)
- We took her to the dog park
but then she'd get really scared,
so she'd, like, only stay with us.
She doesn't like other dogs, I think.
- [Felix] Other dogs.
(Bang Chan babbling)
(Han laughing)
(mellow synth music)
- Please play with me!
(toy squeaking)
(Bang Chan growls)
- I love Tom Holland.
(all talking over each other)
Oh, Chris Evans.
- [Felix] Chris Evans.
- Yeah, Chris Evans.
Chris Evans recently came here.
- [Han] But Tom Holland was my favorite.
Tom Holland was my favorite.
- Wasn't there the "Stranger Things" cast?
Yeah, exactly, yeah.
(I.N. clicking tongue)
I've seen that one.
(mellow synth music)
Definitely Maniac!
(Bang Chan laughs)
Definitely Maniac.
- Gonna call you Maniac, how's that, huh?
Yeah, you can be called Maniac.
You like that name, don't you? (grunts)
(Bang Chan growling)
- His name is Maniac.
- [Hyunjin] Boxer!
(all talking over each other)
- Boxer, oh yeah.
Boxer!
- Easy, I like that.
- What do you think, Miroh?
You like Miroh?
- Their names would be...
- [Stray Kids] Maniac.
- [Bang Chan] And then we have Easy.
- [Stray Kids] Easy.
- [Han] And this guy is Miroh.
- [Stray Kids] Miroh.
- Yeah.
- Hello, Miroh.
(upbeat synth music)
The puppies!
I think puppies and...
- So energetic.
- Is really free.
- Looking at them, and
kind of them resembling us.
I think that was kind
of memorable, I think.
(members talking over each other)
'Cause they're so chaotic.
But then if you look at us,
we're really chaotic too.
(Bang Chan laughs)
- We're unstoppable.
- Thank you, Buzzfeed!
(all cheer)
- Thank you so much for the interview.
- I mean, we had such a great time.
We've always wanted to
try the puppy interview.
So all these puppies are adoptable
at North Shore Animal League America!
(members cheering)
- They're all adoptable,
so please adopt them
and please show them a lot of love.
- Please look forward to
what we're coming up with next, alright?
So, see you next time.
- See you next time,
thanks so much Buzzfeed.
(all talking over each other)
- Bye!
- [Bang Chan] Come here, Maniac!
(Stray Kids babbling)
- Bye!
- Bye.
(upbeat synth music)